breaking news from ukraine ukrainian
president zielinski says at least 15
people have died in a russian airstrike
on a train station in the central part
of the country this attack
on a day laden with both hope and sorrow
today is independence day the national
holiday marking independence from the
former soviet union today also marks six
months of the russian invasion now in a
moment we're going to have a report on a
nation that was scheduled to celebrate
freedom before a war got in the way
first though we want to go to dw's
matthias berlinger he is in
kiev so we've got this report matthias
on this attack on a train station in the
central part of the country what more
can you tell us
yeah we've just heard that uh 15 people
were killed and several persons wounded
in that attack now today is a day where
many people have expected such attacks
to happen
possibly even on the capital of kiev
this has not happened so far but we've
also heard that quite a few rockets have
been intercepted by air defense by
ukrainian air defense and uh it's not
impossible that some were meant for here
for the for the government buildings
that russia has threatened to attack or
that at least some russian
propagandists have threatened to attack
and we've also seen rockets come down in
other parts of the country in the more
western uhnitsuki region and uh also in
kharkiv we've heard
about explosions so it's clear that
russia is sending a signal at this day
and uh it is uh that and that people
have suffered from russian attacks again
in different parts of the country okay
matias stand by this attack comes as we
said earlier on this independence day in
ukraine celebrations were banned in the
capital kiev for fears of a russian
attack we have this report now on how
ukrainians are finding ways to show
their resistance
russian tanks are lined up in the
ukrainian capital
the message
this is the only way russian military
equipment will appear in kiev
burnt and destroyed
it was unusually quiet as ukrainians
mark their independence day in the
capital
occasionally air raid warnings disrupted
the silence
[Music]
but the mood in the city is defiant
i'm very proud of our country
i'm glad that we came back from europe
where we had fled to to celebrate here
now on this day with our fellow citizens
i believe victory will come
it's a special day for me today
i feel nothing
no fear
i traveled almost 100 kilometers here
from near keith
nothing scares me
you just have
what for us is the end of the war
we used to say peace now we say victory
we won't look for a mutual understanding
with a terrorist even though we
understand the russian language you came
to defend while killing thousands of
people you came to liberate
we finally became united
a new nation emerged on february 24th at
4am
not born
but reborn
a nation that did not cry scream or get
scared one that did not run away did not
give up and did not forget
the president and first lady also
visited a memorial to the soldiers
killed in the conflict
meanwhile ukrainian troops in the east
are locked in a grinding war of
attrition with the russian army
almighty of sperlinger still with us
matias on this independent today we're
talking about a possible war of
attrition now six months into this
conflict
is there anything for ukrainians to
celebrate
well this war of attrition has been
going on for several months now and uh
it's the the fear is that it's
going to be a war of exhaustion actually
and of course then many worries occur
how long will the west sustain its
support to ukraine etc ukraine is making
of course uh sometimes even spectacular
strikes against russian ammunition
depots or supply infrastructures
we've seen these strikes on crimea we
have seen several strikes in the hassan
region mainly in the south where ukraine
was able to take out
seemingly big uh ammunition dumps
which very spectacular explosions etc um
so ukraine is in a better position now
than it was three weeks ago or three
months ago uh when it was just pounded
by this these uh this russian firepower
that was 10 times people estimated at
the time higher than the ukrainian but
still we are not seeing any territorial
or significant territorial gains by the
ukrainians they have been able already a
few months ago to drive back the
russians from some of the positions that
were very close to the cities of kharkiv
and nick mcalive and also of course
the retreat from the kiev area but since
then things are really grindingly slow
the russian advance is also slow but it
is
consistent so
we it doesn't look like
there is going to be a fast turn anytime
soon in this war in martial we have
heard before and during this war
particularly from ultranationalists in
russia that that ukraine is not even a
real
country what has the russian invasion
what has it done
to strengthen ukrainian identity
well that's not only ultra nationalist
that's also putin who has said that um
he has clearly miscalculated of course
the ukrainians saw themselves as a
nation before
what it has done is that it has further
consolidated the feeling of the nation
and maybe also the feeling of a nation
that is united i mean you can't be a
nation and you can be quarreling all
over with everybody the elder with the
younger and the easterners with the
westerners the russian speakers with the
ukrainian speakers and i think after
this 24th of february what has been
deluded is this maybe mistrust of groups
against each other there was a process
that was already on the way at least
since 2014 but also maybe since the
1990s it's been accelerating over the
time but the
24th of february has really
boosted this feeling of of of unity here
and people perceive themselves as more
united than before
dw's matias berlinger with the latest
tonight on this independence day
in kiev
well so far ukraine has been spared that
feared massive invasion by the russian
military dw's william bluecroft takes a
look back at how the war started
and at some of its major turning points
after months of speculation warnings
fears and a massive troop buildup on
three sides of ukraine russian president
vladimir putin finally revealed his
deadly intentions on february 24th first
let's look at how things were on the eve
of the war now russia already occupied
the korean peninsula in the south in
2014 and at the same time helped
separatists take control of part of
ukraine's eastern donbus region now in
that conflict the united nations
estimates 14 000 civilians have been
killed in the years since
now starting february 24th putin
launched a full full-scale invasion of
ukraine by land by sea and by air the
russian leader claims the ukrainian
government has committed crimes against
russian-speaking ukrainians but outside
russia the war is seen as a desperate
effort to stop ukraine's further
integration with the west which putin
views as a threat to his power
now in the first stage of the war until
around the beginning of april russian
forces pounded the capital kiev and
other major urban centers like hakeev
and maria paul entire civilian areas
were flattened millions of people fled
to neighboring countries or to ukraine's
somewhat safer western region
but russia underestimated ukraine's
resistance and its military couldn't
establish air superiority it tried but
failed to surround kiev and decapitate
ukraine's democratically elected
government so after several weeks of
little progress from the north of the
country russian commanders ordered a
withdrawal to concentrate their
firepower on the east
that is the war's second phase ukrainian
troops were outmanned and outgunned and
they were forced to steadily retreat
allowing russian forces to consolidate
gains on the ground now what you see
here doesn't mean that russia has full
control of these areas what we can say
is that in the south and the east is
where russia has advanced the most and
exerts some level of administrative
control it's these areas that have seen
the heaviest fighting
and now we're in a third phase ukraine
says it's fighting back with the help of
us and other western weapons
both sides have suffered tremendous
losses though it's impossible to put a
precise figure on that same goes for the
civilian toll which the united nations
officially puts at thirteen thousand
killed and wounded but they acknowledge
it's likely a gross undercut now it's
unclear what putin's end game is here as
the war becomes one of attrition whether
ukraine has the strength to push back
against russian advances whether russia
has the resources to establish itself as
an occupying power and whether the
winter ahead will freeze fighting and
force some kind of deal
that was dw's william gluecroft there
i'm joined now by maria abdiva she is a
security analyst based in harkief in the
northeast of ukraine when russian troops
attacked her hometown early in this war
she started collecting evidence of
possible war crimes and she committed
herself to fighting russian
disinformation maria it's good to have
you with us tonight
you posted a video earlier today from
the center of heave on this ukrainian
independence day and it got our
attention
let's take a look at it
before the invasion putin was saying
that
russian tanks will be on the streets of
kiev in just several days
well here is the main
street in kiev krishaitic and here are
russian tanks
turmobaric weapons all other heavy
russian military equipment burned and
destroyed by ukrainian armed forces and
thousands of people in kiev are now here
making selfies uh in front of the
destroyed russian military vehicles
maria it is clear that you think that
ukraine has won the battle
i'm wondering how can you be sure that
russia will not win this war
the battle is not over unfortunately for
ukraine uh and we have to be prepared
and we are prepared for a long war the
people i have been speaking today with
in khrushchev the the heart of kiev in
maidan square uh all of them say that
ukraine's goal is to get full
territorial control uh of the temporal
occupied territories and that means that
the war is not over for us and it is
continuing but what has changed and what
does this mean this uh uh
so to say uh installation or
exhibition of destroyed russian military
vehicles in kiev what it means for us
ukrainians uh it is the demonstration
that the putin's goal he has put
while he began this invasion on the 24th
of february were not achieved he did not
achieve anything
of the primarily walls and on the other
hand it shows us that ukrainian troops
were able to resist and fight
effectively because many people
including in the west were doubting that
ukrainian army will be able to do so
maria let me speak to you
you as a ukrainian citizen when you look
back at the past six months of this war
how has your life been changed
my personal life has changed completely
before the war i was an analyst and
expert
mainly working from home
and writing research papers desk work as
you would imagine an ordinary expert
will do and from time to time you know
doing trainings and going into
conferences and this war
turned me into some kind of war
correspondent
because now i wear the helmet the body
armor and go to the front lines to show
the world the what is happening in
ukraine and what russia is doing uh to
my country and let me pick up on that i
i know you you made many videos over the
past six months filming the the
aftermath of russian attacks filming
ukrainian troops
has there been a particular setting or
situation that has stayed with you
yes one one thing happened uh just
recently it was in harkee region uh near
my home city uh there is a
small town of chihuahua and
russia stroke the cultural center there
uh with
the s 300 rockets missiles and people
were uh
sheltering in the basement of the
cultural center and three people were
caught inside and we didn't know if
they're alive or not and the rescue
work continued throughout the night and
one of the rescuers
was helped by the uh actually the
husband of the woman which was
there under the rubble and then there
was the scene when the rescuers found
the crushed body and that this uh
he
seen the husband and i talked to him and
he said that they the couple had two
children and he didn't know how to tell
them what has happened to their mother
yeah it's it's
almost impossible to imagine what that
must be like um
are you
worried as the months
turn into a year maybe longer of having
air raid sirens going off at the same
time you have people
um still
taking their children to school going to
cafes
are you worried that
this this dangerous dichotomy of
normalcy and war time life
will get settled in for ukrainians such
as yourself
this is a question i'm asking the people
in the
forefront in the trenches and what they
say me the soldiers they say we are
fighting here for for other people in
ukraine to have their normal lives the
most important thing for ukrainians and
elsewhere in the world is that please do
not forget that this is a war going on
and this is the sovereign state being
attacked by the enemy and while you do
not forget about that and continue
supporting and providing weapons and all
the other help that is uh that ukraine
gets uh ukraine will be able to fight
further and to resist this aggression
maria abdiva we appreciate you taking
the time to share your insights and your
personal stories on this very important
day for ukraine thank you
you